dans un petit boisé d'hochelaga un
regroupement de citoyens qui
s'inquiètent de leurs futurs voisins
basques qui peuvent partir de ceux qui
ont les moyens vont quitter mais ceux
qui peuvent pas les plus démunis vont
rester là puisque ça va face à faire un
ghetto c'est cette résidente du secteur
au coeur de la mobilisation a pris le
pouls du voisinage il nous parle de deux
choses des espaces verts et de logement
de logements abordables personnes nous
dit ça manque de conteneurs dans le
quartier ça manque de camions personnes
raymond logistique a acheté ce terrain
contaminé en 2016 pour 20 millions de
dollars la plateforme de transbordement
qu'il veut construire pour accueillir
environ 10000 conteneurs et être en
activité 24 heures sur 24 contre les
wagons sont en marchandises et au
transport dans les combats les chronos
transit de chine pour aller au pas puis
les parts ou gênant dans grey's mon à
150 pays après avoir refusé de délivrer
le permis de construire montréal a été
contrainte de le faire par deux
décisions rendues par les tribunaux
l'entreprise poursuit aujourd'hui la
ville pour 373 millions de dollars on
est un citoyen corporatif des comme tout
citoyen qui ont subi des dommages
pendant quatre ans parce qu'elle avait
agi illégalement en constant on a le
droit des dommages non par contre n'est
pas femme et à discuter un groupe de
travail sur les mesures d'atténuation
doit faire ses propositions d'ici fin
septembre il réunit des citoyens des
représentants de la ville et de
l'entreprise ce matin là il découvre les
installations actuelles de raymond dans
le sud ouest de la ville visite guidée
par le pdg de l'entreprise c'est un
industriel horrible parmi eux
une semaine plus tard c'est justement le
quartier de viau ville que le groupe
arpente pour jauger les impacts
potentiels vraiment à elle même listé
les nuisances potentielles de sa plate
forme que ce soit les îlots de chaleur
le bruit et les vibrations ou encore la
vermine
dans pointe-saint-charles un talus
plantés d'arbres c'est par une partie du
site des résidences en face
l'idée d'une zone tampon est aussi
avancée dans hochelaga cela pourrait
être porté par le ministère fédéral des
transports qui saisira la gare de triage
du cn dans laquelle on se trouve en ce
moment pour la céder à la ville de
montréal et ainsi créer un
lien vers qui reliera notre dame au parc
maisonneuve qui pourra être reboisées
et servir aux citoyens
les deux autres candidats aux élections
fédérales la libérale soraya martinez et
le bloquiste simon marchand sont
d'accord avec cette idée de parc
linéaire les citoyens eux s'inquiètent
des travaux en cours qui ne devrait
concerner que la réhabilitation du
terrain le ministère de l'environnement
a envoyé des inspecteurs et assure que
tout est conforme aux autorisations
notre seul espoir et politiques qu'il
faut jamais sous-estimer la force d'une
grande citoyens
ça fait cinq ans qu'il ya des problèmes
avec son projet ses débuts tu vois
continuer à avoir des problèmes je vous
garantis et ils réclament des études
d'impact environnemental mais aussi que
le projet soit soumis au bureau
d'audiences publiques sur
l'environnement sauf que pas de projets
on sait pas de quoi aura l'air le proche
alors comme on sait pas de quoi aura
l'air le projet on peut pas faire des
siennes environnementale pour le moment
c'est tout c'est question de processus
respecté et ce dossier ne manquera pas
d'animer la campagne électorale
municipale je pense qu'il faut faire une
pause faut qu'on se parle mais ça prend
des gens qui sont crédibles pour
s'occuper de ce dossier là il est en
plein droit est-ce qu'on veut exproprier
ça peut-être nous on était prête mais
mal acheté le terrain à l'époque on ne
va pas s'excuser de souhaiter qu'il y
ait du développement économique le plus
vert possible et qui s'inscrit dans une
logique où dans un développement durable
intéressant surtout quand ça en plein
milieu d'un quartier et il faudra aussi
composer avec un autre joueur qui va
passer le long du terrain le rem de
l'est en attendant l'aménagement se
poursuit sur le site bientôt l'étape de
l'asphaltage ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal